great story here from Alex Stein
Primetime Alex Stein Over The Blaze
Alex Stein is suing Congress lady
Alexandria ocasio-cortez for blocking
him on Twitter
now Alexandria ocasio-cortez
blocked Alex Stein on Twitter presumably
because he filmed himself in the steps
of the Capitol yelling about her booty
and how she's a hot sexy Latina and she
actually briefly appeared in the video
and sort of waved and then it was it was
a Charming moment she was being somewhat
self-effacing and then immediately she
started
lamenting this and accusing him of all
sorts of things so she blocked him I
guess shortly after that and Alex Stein
is
is suing for this
I think that Alexandria ocasio-cortez
probably had good reason to block Alex
Stein after he made all of these fairly
crude comments to her but the reason
Stein is doing this is because a bunch
of Libs sued over Donald Trump blocking
them on Twitter
and they said that it is a violation of
their rights as Citizens
to have access to this information from
a public official and so Stein is
applying that same principle here to AOC
and and when it comes to that kind of a
political game I say what is good for
the goose is good for the gander this is
something I've been talking about
certainly a lot this week but I've
talked about it a lot before as well
we have to go on offense
we have to be politically offensive not
just defensive there is no neutrality so
you're never going to just preserve a
status quo
in time and space and history the
circumstances of politics are always
changing are they changing for the
better are they changing for the worse
are they changing for what our opponent
wants are they changing into more of our
political Vision you've got to be on the
offense if you're always just playing
defense that's how you go from
feminism to the sexual Revolution to
redefining marriage to transgenderism to
now the debate over transgenderism
really hinges on can we trans the
five-year-olds or do we have to wait
till they turn eight that's where the
debate is right now which means that the
libs have already won on transgenderism
in fact that's why my speech at CPAC
caused such a stir that's why the libs
had to libelously accuse me of
advocating for genocide or whatever
they're saying now they had to lie about
what I said because what I said was very
simple and it offended their
sensibilities I said you haven't really
won on transgenderism we're not I know
there are some conservatives who have
who in their rhetoric have already
conceded that ground I'm not willing to
do it transgenderism at every single
level at every single stage for
everybody is absurd it isn't true we
should not indulge it anywhere in
society
and they lost it they thought they had
won that battle they thought
conservatives were just going to be on
defense and then the battle was going to
be not should we trans the
five-year-olds or the eight-year-olds
then it was going to be should we twins
trans the two-year-olds or the
three-year-olds and eventually they'd
win the whole thing and they'd move on
to the next bizarre idea they have
you've got to stay on the offense
that that's what got me into trouble
there's a liberal Republican by the name
of Charlie Sykes he used to write for
the Weekly Standard before that went out
of business and he was a prominent name
in conservative politics 20 30 years ago
now he works for the bull work and Bill
Crystal and Advocates all this sort of
liberal stuff but but Charlie Sykes
in his reaction to my CPAC speech said
Knowles could use a different word
he he could have said that we should
challenge confront
oppose resist or push back against
transgenderism instead he chose to use
the word eradicate
that's true Charlie Sykes is right I
could have chosen a word that that
implied that we would put up a modest
little fight against the left's new
assault and then ultimately concede
that's what the right and the
conservative movement have done pretty
much for the last 30 years
we just we confront we push back a
little bit hey oh the libs want to upend
all of society they want to reorder the
fundamental political institution
redefine it they want to push gay porn
on our kids in schools they want to let
all the criminals out of prison they
want to open up our border okay well we
can't we can't really fight we can't
stop that we can't eradicate those crazy
ideas no no let's just
can we would you mind if we just pushed
back a tiny little bit just a little
please stop we'll concede again don't
worry uh no I have no interest in that
I want to win
that's what offended them so much the
libs and the squishes like Charlie Sykes
it offended them because we're using the
language of winning
of no we're not only are we going to
stop the left's latest assault we're
actually going to push them back a
little bit we're going to go after some
something that they thought they had
already won that's the language that
they don't like and that's the language
that we have to use
Ronald Reagan made this point really
really well he said when you're
explaining you're losing
it's kind of ironic because right now
I'm explaining this strategy but I'm
explaining the strategy to fellow
conservatives to articulate the point
Ronald Reagan was making
when you're explaining you're losing
when you're defensive when you're
defending you're losing you've got to
keep pushing forward
well okay maybe you know what actually I
just meant to say I push back a little
tiny bit no I meant what I said I meant
eradicate the whole ideology it's a
Preposterous ideology I'll be talking
about that a little bit tonight up at
the University of Buffalo the libs up at
the University of Buffalo are trying
desperately to shut down my speech up
there tonight
there have been all sorts of uh
movements to get the administration to
cancel it the faculty have tried to shut
this thing down some of the crazy
Anarchist activist types are trying to
threat make threats to shut the thing
down
we're going up there I'm flying up to
Buffalo immediately after this show
and the topic is actually feminism that
we're talking about not not
transgenderism but it's all kind of it's
all kind of related you've got to keep
pushing you've got the libs keep to say
they're not going to stop at Banning
transgender surgeries for five-year-olds
they're going to push it to 18 year olds
and once they do that they're going to
try to articulate a coherent view of
marriage again and then once they do
that they're gonna these terrible
conservatives they're going to try to
restore a normal sexual order again and
and maybe they'll try to rein in some of
the divorce laws and maybe they'll try
to rein in some of the crazy aspects of
the sexual Revolution and maybe they'll
deny the false premises of feminism and
maybe and my answer to them is you're
damn right yeah that's what we're gonna
do we're we're either gonna do that
or we're going to surrender everything
those are the only two options though
there's no middle ground on there's no
neutrality there's no status quo and we
have to do that because the stakes are
very very high
the rest of the show continues now we
have got a very important Tick Tock for
you yesterday was woke Wednesday we were
on the road couldn't quite do it so
it'll be woke with Thursday we will
we'll get to that we will finally get to
speak to you in the chat mercifully
become a member use code Knowles
dailywire.com Knowles for two months
free on all annual plans
[Music]
thank you